You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. P. E. R.
All right. K. Yup. I want to start
with a parental daydream for a second.
It's an idea that's been kicking around
for me since my kids were born. Okay.
Actually the idea itself is pretty old.
It goes back to the 18 hundreds right
around Napoleon's time to a fellow by the
name of John Baptist. Pierre
Antwan. Monet evaluates the
Lamar Lamarck Giambattista Lamar
who according to writers, same keen.
He was really one of the first
grand theorists in biology.
He actually coined the word biology
to really? Yup. His big idea,
as you might know,
is that what a person does in their
lifetime could be directly passed to their
kids very easily. His famous
example was giraffes. Lamarck said,
do you want to know how a giraffe
got his long neck one day?
This giraffe mother draft,
let's say he was looking up into tree
and saw some fruit and had to stretch her
neck and stretch again,
whole lifetime of stretching.
And then when she had a baby stretching,
got into the baby and then that baby
would stretch and stretch and stretching
it.
Him Give a little more stretching to its
baby and eventually over the millennia
what you'd get is a creature with a very
long neck because they're reaching for
the tops of trees. It makes a kind
of common sense really. It does.
And it does make kind of a a folk sense.
He thought it worked with humans too.
His example with humans was a blacksmith.
He thought that because they're
swinging hammers all day,
they got big bulking muscles and then
they would pass the muscles to their
children.
The sneaky idea here is that
the blacksmiths, the giraffes,
they made it happen. They
willed the neck to get longer,
the muscles to get bigger. And the,
the key point is that it wasn't
something in born in them.
It was something they acquire
during their lifetime,
which they passed to their kids. Right.
And that's wrong. That's
not how far we're telling.
Now know that that's not the
case, but, but wouldn't be nice
if that's how it worked.
Let's read the book first and
cause you know, now that I've
got these two kids right now I
find myself thinking like, okay, I know
these kids have their genes half for me,
half for my wife and I know I can't change
those genes and I know fate is going
to give them a couple of random mutations
in those genes that I have no control
over. That is just the cold logic
of Darwinian evolution. Yeah.
What's offensive? I mean the idea that
they could be constrained by their DNA,
maybe one of us gave them a bit of
DNA that's going to hold them back.
It's a terrible thought. This letter
right here. Oh, how about this one?
And so what you do, I
think all parents do this,
is that you slip into this Lamarckian
delusion that what you do with your kids
could somehow rewrite all that that
you can somehow by just being nice,
them reading them stories or
whatever, that you could break
them free of all that. We rewrite
their, their their blueprint. Like,
I dunno, you don't really say it
to yourself that way, but yeah,
you can make a deep difference. Yeah.
Like you can help them overcome you.
Is that cool? Hello?
No, you can't. I know.
That's what Darwin says.
You can't. I know. I know.
Once they're born,
their genes are fixed and change does
not happen in a generation or two.
It happens in really,
really, really slowly.
Gradually achingly slowly one parent's
stretching isn't going to do anything.
See, that's the bummer of
Darwinian evolution. As a
parent, you are a tiny blip
and a very, very long story.
[inaudible]
but this hour we're going to fight
this sort of sad sack feeling of
inevitability and impotence and rewrite
the so-called rules of genetics.
That's right. Today on radio lab,
we are going to lick some rat,
starve some Swedes there.
Realized some women.
I mean we're not going
to do that ourselves. No,
but we're going to play the stories
where these things actually happen. Yes.
I'm Chad. Boom. Rod. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab stick around.
It's going to get messy.
[inaudible]
okay, so let's get going and stick with
your boy the mark just for a second.
[inaudible] okay.
Cause we were talking to science right
across Zimmer and he told us that back in
the early 19 hundreds this um,
tension between the mark and
Darwin got extra tense in a,
in a sort of fascinating way.
Right. And it all started in Vienna
at this really marvelous
place called the VI varium
vape. Varium yeah,
this was a really radical place at the
time because you have to remember that
people studying animals up til
now, they were basically, you know,
studying Lima preserved specimen and so
on at the vivarium as the name suggests,
they had lie, man. It was like a zoo.
Well it was a zoo where there was
all sorts of experiments going on.
You know, the fact is that
taking care of animals,
trying to keep them alive in a
building is not an easy thing,
especially if it's 1903.
But luckily for the vivarium and for our
story, they had a guy, Paul [inaudible]
[inaudible] who was he?
Um, so he, and when was he?
He was born in 1880 in Vienna,
Jewish family by all accounts.
A pretty good looking guy
in, in pictures. He has that,
you know that crazy Einstein fuzzy hair
thing. Virginia's cut. Yep. He's 22,
23 and you already have this reputation
for being amazing at keeping animals
alive that otherwise would just
die.
His reputation was that he could get
inside the mind of say a salamander.
I know just
what I wanted to eat or how much
humidity it preferred. Right.
He was a born nurturer
and he adored animals.
He actually named his daughter a less
Serta, which is a genus of Lizard.
That's the kind of guy he is.
So of course the folks at the vivarium
asked him to build these terrariums and
aquariums and stock them with animals,
including a particular in fib Ian, that
plays a very big part in the story.
The midwife towed the midwife
towed, right? That's right.
You're Sam Kean again and here's he says
what you need to know about the midwife
tote. Basically the midwife toad has
a strange habit for toads. Most toads,
he says love to stay in the water.
They like to hang out in the water and
the females like to lay eggs in the
water. But with the midwife towed,
the female lays her eggs on land
and then the male midwife towed,
comes along,
grabs the eggs and actually kind
of sticks them to his back legs,
like a bunch of whitish grapes and then
hops around with them basically until
they hatch. So he's got to live his life
as a towed with all this baggage on him
just until they hatch and then til
they go off still that's a burden.
If he's carrying a big burden
there is, your wife can hear this,
she cares your kids for nine months
and you're like that pork nail towed.
Anyhow, so you've got this Guy Paul
camera who's good with animals.
He got these toads who hate water and in
one day we can imagine he gets curious
as he's doing his rounds, he stops
by the midwife towed [inaudible] me,
looks down at that little male towed
with a grape stuck to his legs and he
wonders how adaptable is that
little guy. I mean he hates water.
Females seem to hate laying eggs in the
water, but is that the end of the story?
What would happen if I
made them go in the water?
Could they adapt? I know what I'll do.
I'm going to set up a terrarium for
them and I'm going to make it hot.
Really uncomfortably hot,
but I'm going to give them
a base in a water. Nice,
cool water and he would
basically turn the heat way,
way up in music aquariums until
they had to go under water.
You can imagine these tilts are
like, dammit, fine. All right,
I'll get in the water. Maybe
they'd try and jump back out,
but it was still hot so
they'd have to jump back in.
And since the camera kept the heat up,
toads basically had to stay
there in this watery place.
Did they had not evolved for Darwin's
theory would have said, you know,
90% of the toads are gonna die.
There's going to be this massacre of
toads and only a few lucky ones are going
to survive. And those lucky ones,
according to Darwin's theory,
they would have had to have been born
with some random mutation in their gene
that gave them an
advantage in this situation
and that advantage, whatever it was,
because it starts with one individual
and then it gets passed onto the kids and
then onto their kids. It
would take a long, long,
long time to through the whole population
because generally that's how evolution
works. It takes a while.
But according to camera,
here's what happened. When
he heated up the toads,
a little cage that hit spend more
time in the water as expected.
And when it came time to mate,
the males and the females,
they would mate in the water at first
didn't go so well because you know,
if you're Atlanto and you're trying to
have sex in the water, it's kind of hard.
Your slippery partner's slippery.
You just have it evolved for
this and there's no way you can,
at least not quickly.
But according to camera,
shortly after these toads got into the
water, they did begin to evolve fast.
They began to grow these little
puffy things on their hands,
the these kind of rough scratchy pads,
what's known as a nuptual
pad, nuptial path. Right.
It was just what the males needed so
they can grab onto the female and hold
tight while they're mating. And
they didn't have these on land? No,
they did not have them on land.
They disappeared in the water. Yup.
And how long did it take? Right
away, we, in just two generations,
these toads seem to have done something
that should've taken, I don't know,
50 a hundred generations,
maybe more camera thought. Wow.
They can respond to the environment.
Do we revealing it with experiments?
They're not trapped by their genes.
Around 1908 he starts publishing all of
these results and it's big news and he
grabs toads and he hit the road. He hit
the lecture circuit and he hit it big.
He was known for going around and giving
what he called his big show lectures
where he would wow whole audiences of
people and in 1923 he actually comes to
England.
There was a newspaper called the daily
express and they have these headlines
that come out. It says race of Superman.
That's the headline for his
talk race. Then below that,
right below the headline says,
scientists, great discovery,
which may change us all. What's he talking
about? We're just talking about tote.
I thought, it's not just
talking about toads anymore.
He's gone way beyond toads. Ki
extended this idea to people.
He thought that you could kind of
engineer societies by changing the
environment. I just have
to read this to you,
the results and make it probable that
our descendants will learn more quickly.
What we know well will
execute more easily.
What we have accomplished
with great effort,
we'll be able to withstand what injured
us almost to the point of death where we
sought. They will find where
we began. They will account
and this idea won him a lot of fans,
including not surprisingly the Soviet,
yeah. It was a very attractive theory to
them in Moscow because the Soviets may
believe in Karl Marx's idea that human
beings are an improvable species.
That if you can change the conditions
around people, you change the people.
Your camera was saying, you know,
you can do this even on a physical,
but
there are a lot of skeptics and there
were from the beginning when camera
published his results initially, a bunch
of scientists immediately began to say,
wait a minute, hold on here. It
would be nice if life was like that.
But life isn't like that. Life is hard.
People can't just will themselves into
a more perfect form according to Darwin,
life and changes are ruled by chance
and fate and to believe anything else
that's naive. So this whole toad
thing to the Darwinian faction,
it didn't scan really.
So some scientists began to ask Cameron
if they could look at his totes and just
take a little peak for themselves and
every time Canberra or our said no,
they were his specimen, get your own.
It was kind of this
struggle for a few years.
Then world war one came and that
kind of disrupted everything.
Camera for one was sent off to work as
a sensor for the Austrian military and
his lab ended up getting destroyed,
including all his toads except he had one,
he had one remaining midwife
towed. So this whole debate,
two totally different ways of seeing life.
It all came down to this jar with his
towed in it and you have to bear in mind
that at this point it only had one hand
left and right and had been cut off for,
for microscopic slides.
And so you could only see one nuptial
pad and it all comes down to this
and [inaudible]
all of it was just about to fall apart.
What happened? Well, there was a,
a uh, expert on reptiles
named at g Kingsley Noble,
Gladwin Kingsley Noble. What an aim.
The guy, it sounds like trouble.
Oh, you was for camera. He was
mighty skeptical. So he uh,
he actually went to Vienna,
visited cameras lab when camera wasn't
there and he makes a very careful study
of this hand. Andy, when he examined it,
he noticed that there
was a syringe hole there.
And he says this isn't a nuptial pad.
It looks darkened, but that's just ink.
What do you mean ink ink?
Like the big ink witting no,
like India ink. What? No.
Yes, he doctored the toad.
That was the implication except camera
or tried to defend himself by saying,
do you think I'm a dumb cop or an idiot?
Because that's what I would have to be
if I left a forgery with ink standing
around openly in the laboratory where
so many of my enemies would have entry.
So how did he explain it? Well,
he thought it might've been an assistant
trying to frame him because he was
Jewish and you know, there was kind
of antisemitism growing at this time.
So he thought that someone had framed
him and six weeks after a noble published
his results in nature camera or sent a
letter to Moscow turning down a job that
they'd offered him because
it would reflect badly on
the Soviet state. And then
following day camera puts on a suit and
he walks off into the mountains outside
Vienna on a rocky mountain trail and
he shoots himself.
Chase Lamarckism
pretty much died there.
Uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh,
uh,
so then over the next 70 some odd years,
lamarck basically became the poster
boy for like the big dumb idea.
The idea that you want to believe in,
but that, you know, isn't true,
but, but, but there's, but there's,
there's like some hope here because, um,
okay. All right. This is interesting.
Then Carl told us about this
research that showed that if,
if a mother really couldn't quite
remember the details does what a mother
imutual for Carl mouse or rat, I'm trying
to remember, was it rats or mice? No,
it's rats. Rats. Yup. We ended up
talking to the guy who did the work.
Michael Meaney I think. Yeah.
I'm a professor in the Faculty of
Medicine at McGill McGill University in
Montreal. So here's the backstory. About
30 years ago, I was in undergraduates.
Michael was in school and
he got interested in a very,
very basic question about
how things get passed down.
Like have you ever had one
of those moments where you
suddenly are your dad and
it catches you off guard? Oh, of
course. I mean it's pretty common.
But like here's a, for instance,
my dad for my entire life had this
thing where if someone was whistling,
he'd be so, he would like,
they could be whistling six tables over
to a restaurant and he would turn around
and be like, stop that.
Like it was like it was scraping his
very nerves and the other day someone was
whistling and I was like, stop it and
you just hit me. I was like, Oh God,
that was hit. It's never appeared
until now. And you went like,
where did that come from?
Is that a genetic hatred of whistling
that I just had or did I somehow learn
that that in a sort of ass backward
way was Michael's question,
how does that happen? How do these
simple little traits get passed forward?
So, so we started looking at
maternal care. Many years later,
he and this woman, Francis Champagne,
who now works at Columbia University,
they decided to explore this
question looking at in rats.
So we have our rats in
the lab and they thought,
let's just see if we can figure out how
it is that rat mothers pass down their
parenting skills. That's right.
If you were a great rat, mommy,
what would you be doing
with your rat baby?
You would be looking them quite a lot.
Uh, that's what good rap mothers do.
They look their babies
a lot, but she says,
you can tell right away just by looking
at some rat moms don't look their kids a
lot. There's a normal distribution, right?
You got your good parents and you're bad
parents would they decided to do first
was to try to figure out which rat
was which, which interestingly,
counting all the lists,
putting this into context,
you know you have a rat mom and they
have about 16 to 20 babies all at once at
once and we're watching
40 liters at a time.
How do you count those?
That's 40 that's too hard.
You have to look at one cage. Say,
are they liking? Yes. No. Okay.
Move on to the next cage. Yes. No,
move on to the next cage. Yes. No,
you have to do that for five hours
a day for six consecutive days.
Move on to the next cage. Yes. No.
See, this is the story of science
that that doesn't get told no.
That just a mind crushing tedium.
Yes. Yeah. The next day. Yes. No.
Yeah. It drifts into something like
a shopping channel. In any case,
what they saw the end of all this
accounting was, well, first of all,
what they saw was this pattern that rat
pups who got licked a lot as babies when
they grew up,
they lick their babies a lot and the rat
pups who didn't get licked a lot when
they grew up, they didn't
lick their babies a lot.
So the great rat nightmare comes true
with the females become their mothers.
Okay.
I think that makes a lot of
sense actually. It's kind
of obvious, right? Right.
Yeah. I mean we all kind of know this.
There are cycles of abuse or whatever.
You know, like if you're abused as a kid,
you were more likely to abuse your
kid. But still you've got to wonder
why. Why would that happen?
How do those cycles perpetuate?
I mean like with the licking,
is it a teaching thing
where you know,
the babies become good mothers because
they've learned it by watching their
mothers, they've seen it and
they've repeated the experience,
or does it get passed on such a deep
level that doesn't even require teaching?
What do you mean?
So that's the reason of course that
we worked with rats because we can get
inside the brain.
So Michael and Francis looked inside the
brains of these rats and what they saw
was that the rats had been
licked a lot as babies.
They had more stuff in their head. What
do you mean one more brains up more.
What kind of stuff? It brings us more up.
More of this particular kind of protein
that activates maternal behavior.
When rats have more of this protein,
they will act more monthly and they,
they had more.
So we'll think about what
makes proteins legit.
DNA. Well, yes. Genes and
DNA. Yeah. Don't you see some,
how the mother's tongue is getting all
the way down in there and going yeah.
Messing with the baby's DNA.
Is that what you're saying?
That the licking is changing the
baby's DNA. That's what I know.
I'm quite saying that cause you
know that's, that's out again,
that's the rules against the rules.
You can't change your DNA. Yeah.
You can't touch that.
It's off limits. Right.
But that tongue is doing
something to the DNA.
So what is the licking doing now?
That's, that's our challenge.
Do you have any theories for how this
tongue is tickling the DNA or whatever
it's doing? Um, well so then,
so what Michael just
launched into this thing.
What happens when moms lick their
pups is that the puppy comes aroused.
The reason they're more
aroused that the mom's
licking
activates the release of adrenaline
and noradrenaline in the pop,
he says those two chemicals
kick off certain hormonal
systems and one of them is
called the thyroid system, right?
Hormones then get into the brain and they
turn on certain neurochemical signals
and the neurochemical signal that gets
activated during licking is Serotonin as
in the mood chemical. Yep.
So mom's looking activates serotonin and
it's released onto brain cells in the
hippocampus. You still with me, I think
I'm with you started with the tongue.
Four or five steps later.
We are in brain cells.
So almost instantaneously the mother's
tongue has reached into the baby's brain
cells.
Now inside the cells in the center
coiled up little spools is the DNA.
So we're getting close to the
moment of truth gets there. It is.
That's the stuff that makes you you,
but that you supposedly can't get to.
But here's what I did not know
about DNA. According to Francis,
it's not just sitting off.
They're perfectly preserved.
It's in the middle of
the cell, it's crowded.
You've got all these chemicals
around racing by, you know,
in the south and very often
one of them will just go
crashing into [inaudible]
DNA and it'll stick there like a,
like a barnacle or a glob
of peanut butter. Exactly.
Peanut butter. There we go.
What will happen is it'll get stuck to
one little part of the DNA and now that
little bit of DNA is
very difficult to get at.
It's basically unusable because it's
got the thing stuck to it. Yeah,
and these things are called
apparently methyl groups.
Methyl groups are pretty
sticky. They're hard to get off.
So imagine the DNA in that brain cell.
All of these chemicals racing
by crashing into it sticking.
And one of the bits that gets covered
up is that little bit that makes the
proteins that create a maternal instinct,
the bit of DNA that will give this baby
when it grows up instincts to be nice to
its baby and lick that. And you're saying
that part of the DNAs covered up? Yes.
And when methyl groups stick
to that part of the DNA,
the maternal instinct is
effectively turned off.
But if you've got a mom who licks you,
mom's looking activate Serotonin,
serotonin gets into the brain
cells and according to Michael,
unleashes a whole series of
molecular events inside the cell.
The critical part of this is
that all these changes wake up,
this little gang of proteins
known as transcription factors.
And if they see methyl groups sitting
on that bit of DNA, they are pissed.
And so they bring water friends to the
party, they all go down to the VNA,
surround that methyl and just
knock it right off the DNA. That's it.
And then they're going to basically
rebel at that particular spot.
Turn on that gene.
So now the genes can make the proteins
that make the rats a good mom. Exactly.
Exactly. That was awesome. Wow.
That was amazing. Why? Why are you
so thrilled? Well, think about it.
This is nature and nurture slamming into
each other. Like you know when people,
smart people say, you know,
there's no such thing as nature.
Notice on the interaction
at the tail and you're like,
what the hell does that mean?
Well, this is it, right?
This is real physical,
chemical interaction between what's going
on in the environment and what's going
on with the DNA.
Because you begin with a mother's
lick that ends up with a deep,
deep change in the baby, not just
the good, warm, fuzzy feeling,
but a fundamental shift.
Who that baby is and
who that baby will be.
You're now hearing the Mark's name invoked
these days because there are things
beyond genes that we pass
down to our children.
No, according to Carl
[inaudible], gs are still fixed.
We can't rewrite our genes. That
is impossible so far as we know.
But there seems to be this
layer on top of the genes,
this second channel of heredity.
If the genes are the bottom floor,
then this layer on top is
sometimes called the Epi genome.
And that thing can change
based on your experiences,
which wouldn't you think about it?
It has a very lamarckian flavor.
Yeah. I think that's where the Mark's
ideas can be woven in and make some sense.
So do you call yourself a Lamarckian?
Not usually because it upsets people.
And I'm Canadian. I
don't like to [inaudible]
[inaudible] plus, you know,
the Marc didn't get all the
biological details right?
I had no idea about DNA or very many
of them right at all. But you know,
his basic idea seems to be true.
I mean, when you think of camera,
there was a report in science, um,
outlining a theory about how cameras,
toads got these characteristics
that invoked the,
these epigenetic inheritance
and, and imprinted genes.
And it made it plausible.
Oh, so redeeming him. Yeah.
Maybe or maybe not.
[inaudible]
thanks to Francis Champagne
and Michael median. Sam Keen,
who writes about Paul Camera in his
book, the Violin, his thumb. Also,
thanks to Carl Zimmer, whose latest
his evolution making sense of life.